crowdsourcing is a subset within open  innovation where we rely on hundreds if  not thousands of people  working in parallel sometimes  competitively or collaboratively to go  solve problems that we may care about  crowdsourcing  basically burst into the scene in the  early 2000s when we started to see  companies and platforms emerge that  relied on the wisdom of the crowd to  help us write wikipedia articles to help  us write software code and to even solve  the toughest science problems so  crowdsourcing fits in within this  broader paradigm that ideas reside  outside of the company and the best ways  for a company to innovate is to often go  to the outside world and bring it  [Music]